it is true as of 11 weeks ago i decided
to move myself
my family my two dogs as well as
valuetainment off to florida
specifically
south florida and today i'm going to
answer to you
why out of all the places i could have
gone to i could have gone to north
dakota
i could've gone to wyoming i could have
gone to the great state of montana
why florida we're going to talk about it
today
[Music]
so i got to give you the backstory
before i tell you why i moved to florida
so
i'm like a gypsy my dad calls me a gypsy
because like in armenian they say titi
chest got honest meaning you can't sit
still in one place i lived
10 years in iran i lived 18 months in
germany at a refugee camp i lived six
years in glendale california then i
lived nine months in south carolina
columbia
then i lived in kentucky tennessee for a
couple of years back to la for 21 years
dallas for five years and now south
florida for the last 11 weeks so why did
i go from specifically
california to texas to florida so let's
talk about the move from california to
texas
when i left california i wrote a love
letter to california
it looked like this if you want to read
the whole thing you can read it all the
way at the bottom
i'll leave the link for you to read it i
wrote why i'm leaving california i also
wrote what i think california needs to
do this letter was written probably
in 2016 february 1st give or take
but i explained why i was moving to
texas and these were my
reasons on moving to texas when i wrote
this five years ago
so my number one reason was
entrepreneurship and there was an
article at the time that came out in
2016 that said
it was by cnbc ranking california 50th
for business friendliness i wanted to go
to a little bit more of a friendly place
for entrepreneurs that was texas four
seasons
my kids enjoyed christmas we wanted to
move there for the four seasons
southern hospitality the service in
texas is fantastic the people are so
friendly
cowboys and the texas rangers i've
always been a big texas rangers fan
and they got cost of gas it was a buck
58 at the time in texas versus 258 at
the time
in california then taxes california is a
lot of taxes let's face it it's the
worst
in america in taxes and texas was the
seventh best state at the time in texas
easy to travel anywhere in the country
due to its airports cost of living was
great
traffic was different than california
and obviously a great place to make
contacts
for business in the state of texas so
that's my reason why i moved to texas so
now the question because pat
if you love texas so much why florida
why would you go from texas to florida
and i'm going to answer that to you but
do me a favor if you like this content
so far
and if you like valuetainment press the
thumbs up button and if you're here for
the first time
smash that subscribe button so let me
get right into it why did i move to
florida from texas
it's kind of confusing right let me
explain it to you about a year and a
half ago
we're sitting there saying long term
what do we want to raise our kids right
all my friends are in california and i'm
a big friend relationship friendship i
love my community la i grew up in
glendale granada hills
northridge you know chance ward woodland
hills that's my area that's my stomping
ground i know the people there
have a lot of contacts i want to go back
to right i went to glendale high school
but my wife and i were sitting there
saying long term if we could live
anywhere
for the rest of our lives because we
moved 11 times in the last 11 years
what would it be so we put newport beach
at the top we're gonna go live in
newport beach
love newport beach it was a house i
always had my eyes on
it was on a market it's a beautiful home
it was a former home
of a guy that used to mentor me 20 years
ago when i was 21 years old i wanted to
buy that house it had some sentiment to
me
and i wanted to buy that house and i
said how about greenwich because if
we're going to run a media company
it'd be great if we're in new york so i
looked at these two homes in greenwich i
said i'd like to go to greenwich
finance meets media meets investments
there's so many different things you can
do in new york
then i look briefly at nashville
tennessee i used to live there i loved
living in nashville tennessee
maybe we stay in texas those were our
options then the pandemic kid the moment
the pandemic kid we were kind of sitting
around saying now what do we do
we've never experienced good states
shutting down you got to put a mask what
are you talking about
this has never happened to me before and
then we watched all the governors and
states on how they handled it
the way california handled it it was an
atrocity
homelessness went to the roof in the
state of california
i went back to visit l.a where my dad
used to live in granada hills i could
not believe how many homeless people
were around that petted park
there was no homeless folks at petted
park and then my
sister would send me videos of streets
i'm like there's no way this is true
then i went to a party one time in l.a
during that time during covet by the way
and i went
and drove for two three hours with the
just looking at what's going on in
venice and la
in beverly hills bridges freeways i'm
like i've never seen this before
then stats came out about the state of
california did you know according to hud
in america we have a total of
580 000 homeless people give or take add
another 50 to 100
000 in the last 12 months but around
580. did you know out of the 580 000
homeless people in america 160 them live
in california
did you know that 160 that live in
california 60 plus live in l.a in the
last 12 months
that 60 000 in l.a has gone up 20 000 of
homelessness in california
and they don't protect the small
business owners they don't protect the
guy that's running a shop they don't
care if he can lay out on the front and
customers don't want to go there because
they're afraid and they're not taking
homeless
taking care of homeless folks or the
veterans that don't have a place to stay
at
no investment back into that and i'm
sitting there saying i don't know if
it's going to be california
so california went off the list simply
because of homelessness
and we looked at greenwich we've lived
in cold different places it was actually
very basic decision
then we saw how uh you know cuomo was
making a decision in the state of new
york
i watched how much wealth new york lost
nearly 350 billion dollars of wealth
that left new york to other places
and then we saw the increase of
population going
in couple different states texas was
grown florida was growing and we saw
texas and florida handle the entire
pandemic
texas they played a little bit more
protecting their small business owners
california said no you cannot they give
them fines snitch on people
if people are partying outside and
they're outside so california is
breeding a snitching environment
and new york was no restaurants clothes
restaurants clothes restaurants clothes
new york is all about restaurants a
bunch of beautiful restaurants that we
used to go to shut down
and then i'm noticing disneyland closes
in california but disney world stays
open in florida i said hey
we got out florida to the option we
looked at tampa and we looked at the
other side with fort lauderdale
boca area miami area and we made our
decision so that's the whole process and
now let me give you my specific reasons
why we chose the state of florida so
taxes i like states with no taxes and
that only leaves me with a few of them i
think it's only seven of them nevada
being one of them washington be another
one tennessee being another one
then you got uh texas you got florida
and you got a couple others out there
right so
amongst those seven states that are no
taxes
i wanted to know which one offers the
best lifestyle florida became the place
where i wanted to be
to not have any kind of state taxes
where you can go out there and create
commerce create business
and you don't have to pay the state
taxes federal is already going up
corporate taxes are already going up i
don't want to also have state taxes on
on top of wealth tax corporate tax
capital gains tax income tax at least
let me have one of them
in that state tax so florida you don't
have any state taxes
that's point number one second thing
about florida was lifestyle i kind of
wanted to have the lifestyle type of an
opportunity which means if i want to get
a boat
if i want to get a yacht if i want to
take my kids fishing if i want to
middle the day take my kids to the beach
and come back and we swim for two hours
and come back to the office
it's literally a quarter of a mile this
way i go i get on i'm good i come back
to the office i want to be able to do
that
i want to be able to say hey let's go
have dinner last week dinner on a yacht
with a person
in you know palm beach you got a
132-foot yacht we have nice food i like
nice caviar enjoy it went back to the
house it was good to go so i wanted the
lifestyle part
all sports i got disney world two hours
away universal
studios a couple hours away if i want to
go to naples 128 miles away if i want to
go
and all this stuff lifestyle wise was a
beautiful place to be
food restaurants yacht ocean
beach and all of that stuff or lifestyle
florida offered
that texas didn't offer so we chose
number two as lifestyle
next one was economy i want a state
that's got a very strong economy
obviously if we look at data at the top
of economy
in states is california is number one
then you got texas
then you got new york then you got
florida i've lived in three out of those
four states the only one i haven't lived
in is new york i've lived in california
texas and florida now
so i wanted to be in a place that's
economically doing better why because
the pool of talent
of who i can recruit is higher out of
those four
lifestyle wise california florida
probably best than i would say new york
than texas
then between california and florida i
chose florida when it comes down to
economy
because i can recruit talent to florida
if i tell somebody from new york
i'm growing a business in the state of
florida i can recruit folks from new
york to florida
i can recruit folks from chicago to
florida i can recruit folks from detroit
to florida
it's going to be a little bit of a
different place if i'm telling people to
move to different places but i know
i could recruit talent to the state of
florida
due to its economy next thing was about
finding a place where i can also recruit
my friends and family because
i'm not moving to florida to just be by
myself i want to go out and recruit my
favorite people in the world
talent friends family
the people i enjoy their company the
most
i'm coming for you i'm gonna come
recruit you i
want you in the state of florida right
like uncle sam says
but i want my friends and family to be
in this great state of florida to enjoy
it with me so
whether some of my friends who are
extremely wealthy and they want to get a
10 million dollar house or 20 million
dollar house underwater
yacht parked in a back gated community
country club on the side
and you can go in with your boat and go
have dinner somewhere and come back
you have that here but also
affordability when it comes down to
housing
you also have that here did you know
when it comes down to price of homes in
the state of florida where it ranks
amongst other states
let me give you some states that are
more expensive to buy a house in
than the state of florida connecticut
arizona virginia
nevada maryland new york new jersey
oregon
colorado washington massachusetts
and hawaii cost more to buy home there
than the great state of florida and yes
california is the highest if you take
hawaii they are the most expensive place
in america
to own real estate and since 1990
california's lost three and a half
million people that have left california
on top of that during the pandemic
san francisco took the biggest hit of
people leaving san francisco
in texas they show registration of how
many people change their ideas because
when you go to texas
you show your idea whatever state you
left and they kind of book it to see
where you're coming from
san francisco grew some 50 percent uh uh
from
from uh uh from what he called it from
uh san fran to texas
the number is between 32 to 50 percent
of growth from there as well as
florida people are leaving these places
so i wanted a place
where affordability if you're living in
a half a million dollar home in florida
and texas
you buy a half a million dollar home in
florida it's going to be a nicer home
than you have
in the state of california versus
florida so affordability
cost of living you know what you need to
do out there is still affordable in the
state of florida remember when i said
i'm living in a place where i want to
recruit my friends and family over
i also want to recruit some of the older
family because sometimes when you're
recruiting friends and family
first thing they say is what do i do on
my father
he's 78. what do i do with my mother she
helps me with the kids
she's 75. what can i do to have her
leave the state of california or new
york or chicago or somewhere else
well here's a basic stat for you do you
know what's the number one state in
america for retirees
where people go to retire it's the state
of florida you know why
because it's beautiful for them to take
a walk outside amongst other people
they make friends so many boomers here
so many people to have friends and make
friends with
so yes it's also a wonderful place not
only for you if you're in your 20s 30s
not only for those of you that are 40s
50s in a hunt it's also great for those
in their 60s 70s
and 80s to live in the state of florida
next one is weather i like the fact that
i can go outside it'll rain for 30
minutes 30 minutes later it's 82 degrees
beautiful you're enjoying it now don't
get me wrong
i've been here during the summer it gets
very humid and i'm talking
really really humid but i'm from iran
i'm kind of used to the heat and i kind
of like the heat and i lived in
california not only in california i
lived in chatswort
have you been to chatsworth during the
summer have you seen what happens in
chatsworth during the summer when it
gets to 110 degrees
during the summer in chatsworth yes i
was able to make it through that so the
heat doesn't bother me
going to negative 20 is what bothers me
but 110 degrees i can tolerate it
although it doesn't get to 110 here i
don't even think it cracks 100
it's 92 95 any of that that's the
weather now some people come back and
say pat
how about hurricanes you're right how
about hurricanes
but in any state i live in i got a
natural disaster
in california i got earthquakes i've
been through the 94
northridge earthquake for 45 seconds
when i was
in van nuys living in that apartment
with my dad on base it
and the building was going like this for
45 seconds freeways dropping
and one thing about earthquakes they
don't give you a warning they just say
poof we're here shaking your house right
then people say what about what about
hurricanes though what about tornadoes
texas i've been through tornadoes
multiple times before my lifetime
and they just come you go this way it
comes this way you go the way it goes
that we can't
you can't get on a plane because it's
going to the airport tornadoes are funny
and like this they get started with no
warning the warning you got is maybe
a couple hours right i've been through
war in iran we've been bombed on
cold weather is pretty much nonstop if
you've lived through chicago whether
it's pretty bad to live through it
and then you have hurricanes you know
it's a good thing about hurricanes and
bad things about hurricanes when it
comes it's pretty ugly and if you look
at what happened to homestead
years ago it ain't pretty a lot of
damage the numbers are
terrible was an atrocity when it took
place so developers have learned how to
develop stronger buildings
here the homes built in california would
never make it here in florida just so
you know that
they don't build homes here on wood
maybe the older home all the ones but
the new ones are stronger
but the thing about hurricanes is you
have two to five days warning
to choose to leave you can go to a
different place you don't have to stay
here
so it at least gives you a warning and
say hey a
crisis is coming your way move if you
want your chances to be lower of you
being hit and then you move
you have that ability but the reality of
it is natural crisis
doesn't go away no matter where you and
i live some people would even call the
homelessness in the state of california
as a natural crisis because it affects
the economy in the state of california
but it is what it is so that's the part
with weather as far as florida goes
next one is politics what do i mean by
politics florida is as purple as it gets
which means what you got democrats
you got republicans i live in a
community where one yacht comes by
massive flag of trump today and then the
next flat comes by
and they got a flag of obama or biden
mostly biden you'll see right trump by
community
one's got a biden flag one's got a trump
flag trump flags are everywhere you'll
see biden's flag here and there you'll
have debates
some are democrats some are republicans
it's purple the discussion is there
they're willing to have that
conversation if you in the state of
california if they find out you vote
republican they want to tell everybody
if you in the state of new york it's
also the same
here it's welcoming you're a democrat
great you're republican great you're an
independent great
you're libertarian great it's florida
they understand it they're used to it
because they got them on both sides and
they can handle it
next one is regulation if you're a
business owner you know exactly what i'm
talking about state of california
regulation is a little rough new york
rough some of the parts illinois
michigan rough florida regulation
benefits the creator so if your creator
state of florida is
very attractive for creators mayor
suarez sent a tweet the other day
talking about how he can help in miami
how he can help to bring
more of silicon valley to miami he is
working with elon musk to want to bring
more traffic here let's build
he is wanting to be innovative he was
saying a couple nights got an event we
were at at soho house he says
i'm about having to pay the least amount
of taxes for you guys the job creators
i want to create an environment where
you guys can grow and develop new
business
and he went through the whole thing with
tech crypto creative he wants to bring
silicon valley here
it's a type of an environment where a
business owner can excel
and grow this is why so many of the
major financial firms in the state of
in the new york city are moving to
florida because they're realizing this
could be the potential future hub
of the financial industry the way it's
going regulation a very big part of my
decision to come to florida cultural
culture to me is very big and what i
mean by culture is i like every
ethnicity
i don't care if you're white black
mexican salvadorian guatemalan honduras
you know bolivian cuban puerto rican
dominican
asian filipino armenian assyrian russian
i'm gonna miss a lot of them i don't
care what you're i want my kids to go to
a place
where they meet everybody because my
kids are a mutt because their
dad is half armenian half a syrian born
and raised in iran
they look a little bit different they
don't look like a white boy they don't
look like a middle eastern so it's kind
of like i kind of don't know what
nationality you are kid my kids right
and i like culture i like culture from
all walks of life so i wanted to raise
my kids in a place
where they get a flavor of culture this
place has got a lot of culture
the other thing is travel if i live in
the state of california if i want to
travel california to
west i got five and a half hours to go
to hawaii right so that's still a five
and a half hour flight right
but if i live in florida if i want to go
to cuba 45 minutes away
one hour away if i want to go to bimini
in a yacht
couple hours away in a yacht right if i
want to go to
london eight hours away if i want to go
to you know paris is right if i want to
go to new york two and a half hours if i
want to go to toronto
three hours if i want to go to dc a
couple hours if i want to go to
it's everywhere right where i want to go
if i want to go to the caribbean if i
want to go to mexico if i want to go to
belize if i want to go to a bunch of
these different places it's
right here to travel it's not far so
east gives me more options than west
does
when i live in the state of california
the next one is kind of tricky let me
explain to what i mean by this because
so so think about if you're most people
from europe they want to go vacation to
where
miami people from california i really
want to go party in miami
from you know i really want to go to
panama city in florida
for whatever summer for fourth of july
labor memorial okay great
you know i really want to go to naples i
really want to go to orlando for disney
tourists come here non-stop it's a big
number it's 130 140 million people that
come here
pre-covered tourism is high which means
what there's always an excuse
to get people to come and visit you
friends and family
would be willing to come and visit you
because you're in a vacation place
you're living
in a vacation state if that makes any
sense that's also california it's also
new york
those are two benefits they also have as
well but so is miami
it's a vacation hub so it's very easy to
know that
imagine waking up every morning and you
live in a vacation hub
so you're on a vacation yet you're
working it's kind of confusing right
like
you're working in a place where people
go to vacate
it's an interesting dynamic i don't know
if it makes sense to you but it's a
beautiful place to live
while the rest of the world comes here
for vacation something to think about so
those are my reasons why i chose to move
to florida i'm not telling you it's the
end-all be-all i'm just telling you it's
why i
chose to move to florida some people may
be saying i want to go to texas
remember the whole thing about life is
sequencing this chess piece that's
sitting behind me it's about what moves
you make in what order i lived in texas
for five years best thing i did texas
treated me royally because i was three
hours from california
three hours from washington i could go
to chicago like this new york in three
hours
miami in three hours it was a perfect
place for me for that five years that i
was there
some of you florida may not work for you
because if you've got a business in
california that's a 12
hour travel time going back and forth
some of you may need to stay in
california right not this phase of your
life because you're in hollywood
entertainment your job is paying you
well no one's going to pay you a better
job
even though you're paying taxes in
another state you're making four hundred
thousand dollars here another state that
may pay 280
but you're not paying state it may make
sense for you to stay where you're
staying at so i'm not
sitting here telling you it's end-all
be-all i'm just telling you for me
it was a phenomenal place to move today
at this
phase of my life and if you're watching
the same path you know you got me
thinking about potentially moving to
another state i did a video about 10
months ago titled
10 reasons why you ought to consider
moving to another state if you've never
watched this
click over here to watch the video and
on top of that if you want to read that
love letter
that i wrote to california five years
ago click over here
to read that love letter take care
everybody bye
you